[Music]
so the whole if you just look at the
application ecosystem today I think it's
very fair for us to say that there are
some fundamental characteristics that
the applications that we build today
have regardless of whether you're
building a departmental application or
an internet scale application the speed
and the response time for applications
are super important in today's world you
couple that with scale you couple that
and you add high availability and you
add the the need to run application
infrastructure at a certain operational
cost it becomes a very interesting
problem so when it comes to caching why
is caching so such a fundamental
infrastructure when it comes to
applications right caching is not a new
concept right everybody everybody uses
caching from our perspective the use
cases that we see when we see customers
use caching primarily is around two
high-level use cases one is the obvious
one which is latency right you want to
reduce latency off the application you
want to have an in-memory caching layer
in between your application layer and
your database layer that's some the main
use case the other one that we also see
customers use is the reduce cost so you
can argue that if you have a back-end
database where you are charged at for
the ops per second or the number of ops
that you're using for the back-end a
caching layer in between can actually
help you reduce calls so that's one of
the other use cases that we see
customers use or the benefit that
customers try to get out of caching but
the the second the second use case or
the second benefit is kind of tricky
because you have to be very careful in
terms of how you slice your cache and
not get into this whole notion of a ton
during her problem if part of the cache
goes down you have enough capacity on
the back-end etc so that's that's that's
the specific case where you even want to
be super careful in terms of how you
design your cache system but when you
look at the use cases and there's a
whole bunch of them right I mean
literally across all different types of
applications caching is used
and I don't think we need to elaborate
on that but the whole idea is that you
have a cache in your application of
structure so that you can the data
access layer can get the frequently
accessed data from memory rather than
from disk but there's a whole bunch of
things behind it in terms of how to
optimally though the cache and go talk
more about that from a caching pattern
perspective I would say the read through
cache is fundamentally what everybody
uses mostly right which essentially says
that hey go try to get the the data from
cache if it's not there go read it from
the database and once you read it from
the database cache it so that subsequent
queries can get the data from the cache
so that's kind of the fundamental
caching pattern that most applications
use but then we also see right through
caching patterns how many of you use
right through today or any
implementation of right through so right
there is an interesting case where it it
it is supposed to solve a lot of the
problems around cache consistency but it
is it is a complex logic and there are
issues that comes our consistency issues
that can crop up and there are a lot of
error conditions that you need to watch
out for
so essentially right through caching
means you write to the cache first and
then write to the back in database and
you Lee commit once the writes are in
both the places and right behind
essentially which is very very rarely
used means you just write to the cache
first and late and you lazily write it
to the back-end database so that's an
eventual consistency model and any
eventual consistency model
that really depends on your application
right so if your application can
tolerate that kind of a model great but
the other the other one that we also see
is in process or what I mean by in
process is that if you have if you want
to have an application close to you or a
cache close your application note for
example you can have for example a redis
process running directly in your
application know to cache like local
data so the reason I bring that up in
this context is because sometimes when
you have a managed service that gives
you like a managed Redis which is kind
of a distributed centralized cache the
in process caching use case you may be
better off just deploying your own bread
along with for example if you're running
GE and if we are running your
application notes in GK it may be better
off just running Redis directly in the
know rather than using a centralized
management manage cash but these are
some of the different varying caching
patterns that we see so white Redis I
think everybody knows about Redis but I
think just to quickly summarize we all
know Redis is a very versatile dating
memory data store it is categorized
let's keep Ali store but there are so
many different uses of it that it is I
feel it is more than just a Chiari store
but if you look at the key capabilities
of Redis from just you know forget about
the latency part which is pretty obvious
but the data structures is one of the
most powerful aspects of Redis right
there are all kinds of different data
structures that allows you to
efficiently process data for various use
cases and I'll touch upon that a little
bit but the other things like high
availability and persistence also make
it a lot more usable in for different
use cases right and I'll talk about
these characteristics and the use cases
in just a bit
there's capabilities like pops of
scripting modules and now streams in
Redis file which is pretty powerful when
it comes to processing streaming data
and when we talk about use cases
obviously there are all kinds of
different use cases the very common ones
that we see at least and what we have
seen with memory store is obviously the
first I would say four are pretty common
so caching straight-up query caching a
session store is very very common with
Redis so essentially you basically want
to have your session stored in Redis and
rate-limiting we have a lot of customers
basically using Redis for API
rate-limiting that's one of the common
use cases that we see fastened just as
an interesting use case where you can
use various data structures within Redis
to basically quickly process streaming
data into your pipeline so
when you look at these use cases like I
said right there are different data
structures that you can use to basically
support these use cases I think most of
you are probably very familiar with it
if you're already using Redis I'm just
listening a few sessions to like for
example hash is a very interesting data
structure in Redis hash essentially
allows you to basically take a set of
key values and basically put them no
higher level data structure and it's
like very memory efficient so one of the
things that we recommend is if you are
using essentially just plain key value
it's probably a lot of key value pairs
it's probably better to take a look and
see whether you can convert that into
hash hashes because it's very memory
everything sorted set is also very
powerful solids it is essentially it's a
mapping of members this course right
allows you to easily sort through the
scores and basically give you a what is
a top 10 for example player or the top
10 players in a game etc so I'm not
gonna go deep into those I just want to
give you a quick overview in terms of
why you know why Redis is so popular and
looks like a lot of you are already
using Redis so the interesting thing
about you know it when you move to the
cloud one of the key benefits that
everybody wants to get is that you don't
want to manage your own application
infrastructure that is fundamentally one
of the key benefits that everybody's
looking for so from a database portfolio
perspective you probably will see the
slide through many sessions but the
point is that we offer a variety of
databases managed as managed services so
called memory store is our managed in
memory data data store and it's
essentially manage stratus and I'll talk
more about called memory store going
forward and we also have the
non-relational databases of cloud
BigTable which is our white column store
obviously called spanner which is our
distributed relational database bigquery
which is our data warehouse and the
other thing you if you listen to the
keynote one of the things that we are
also trying to do is to work very
closely with our partners and make sure
that if there are capabilities that the
partner ecosystem provides you can
easily get that from Google
in a very integrated manner so the
bottom line here is that there's a
portfolio of services that we provide
and the key goal for us is to provide it
as a managed service so that you don't
have to do the work in terms of managing
these infrastructure all right so let's
dive into the core of the talk which is
cloud memory store this is a high level
you know I would say marketing slide but
the key point here is that there are
three things I'd be trying to optimize
for when we run this managed service one
is it's going to be fully managed by us
so what that means is that any kind of
patching security vulnerabilities that
come from Redis etc we automatically
take care of you we probably have
already done two security patches
already that comes from Redis we get
notified even before you get to know so
we take care of all that the other thing
that we really focus on is this
availability and reliability of the
service right I will for me as a product
manager I keep telling my team that
reliable these our number-one feature
right and because that is fundamentally
what do you expect us to do from a
managed service perspective so when it
comes to reliability I'll talk about the
different offerings that we have and the
kind of capabilities that we provide
with cloud memory store but the key
thing is that we use replication we have
automatic failover and we also provide
as a ways around it and the last thing
last but not the least from a security
perspective be a sense that we have all
various capabilities that we provide to
make sure that the system is secure and
I'll talk more about the details of that
so memory so if you're not if you're not
use memory store the memory store comes
in two flavors one is what we call the
basic tier and that's essentially a
standalone instance of Redis these are
so standalone and sends them if you ask
the question what do you get with that
sound rule instance we essentially take
care of all the health monitoring we
take care of the automatic recovery from
failures the other thing that we also do
is that I took IP preservation so in
case the system goes down and comes back
up you get you're guaranteed to have the
same IP so from an application
perspective you don't have to worry
about IP changes the standard here is
the replicated Redis instance
what we provide with standard here is a
cross zone replicated Redis right so you
have reticence inside is replicated
across zones we automatically take care
of the failover and it's a single
endpoint so we essentially have a
virtual IP that is in front of the
instance and when a failure were happens
or if the node fails back and forth
you're essentially connecting to a
single IP so there's no IP change when
that happens and we allow you to you
know scale up and down seamlessly and
I'll walk through the demo and show you
how this works
in actuality in the demo but we also
provide three nines of availability for
the standard tier service and the other
thing that I want to kind of quickly
touch upon is that the way we have
exposés service essentially is that you
Redis is a single-threaded service so
what we what we are essentially done is
behind the scenes we have create we
cheered the service meaning the more
memory you provision you get more
network throughput so behind the scenes
what's happening is that we adjust the
number of CPUs are be provisioned
depending on the size of the instance
that you're provisioning so the higher
the memory the higher the throughput
that's the that's a provisioning model
and I'll show that in the demo in terms
of how that works
so we event GA probably we've ng about
six months back and we've been doing a
lot of work behind the scenes to provide
more features so we have Redis for Oh
currently in beta we are working on
Redis 502 the other thing that we are
enabling as of next is the act ability
to access memory store from App Engine
standard second generation Rob times how
many of you use App Engine at all it
doesn't matter
or is it useful yes so again the point
that I want to make here is that it's
only for a second gen runtime so if
you're using App Engine standard first
generation runtimes obviously that only
supports App Engine SDK we memory sorely
supports
as protocol so if you're using second
gen runtime you can essentially connect
to memory store the other thing that
we've been asked quite a bit from
customers is the ability to test your
application before you deploy especially
when you're using sanity or instances so
one of the things that you want to be
able to test is the failover the
behavior renew when do you service field
so so we have exposed a manual failover
command that you can use to test your
service before you know before you
deploy we added a bunch of new
monitoring metrics we've learned a lot
since GA in terms of how customers are
using it so we are exposing more and
more metrics to be helped you understand
how your system is behaving and how you
want to react to that so the best
practices section we will actually walk
through each of these metrics and what
are some of the things that you should
be monitoring and watching out for and
lastly we've been continuously adding
regions we are pretty much all over the
pretty much in all regions except maybe
like three or four which we probably
will roll out pretty quickly and then we
are continuing to work on our compliance
support for memory store so this is
probably interesting for folks who
haven't used memory store so I just want
to walk through the product and give you
an overview but at the same time answer
some questions around the you know
certain characteristics of memory stores
so memories are essentially is listed
under the storage portfolio in Google
Cloud console and it's pretty straight
forward I think we made it pretty simple
to go and provision a Redis instance I'm
just gonna create one right now so from
a version perspective we recommend that
you start using 400 if you are going to
start using memory store now we support
both 3.2 and 400 we will currently smart
beta but we will go GA pretty much in
like a few weeks but we highly recommend
that you start using furro going forward
and this is where I was talking about
the tiers you can select either basic of
standard tier this is going to select
static here so what happens in the
standard tier essentially is
right as a memory source a regional
service what we call a regional service
so you can pick any region that you want
to deploy to so as you can see people
pretty much in most of the regions today
and the zone essentially you can leave
it and any and people pick the zones for
you
is there any reason anybody need to pick
a zone in your use case like specific
zones for Stan for a rebus instance so
yeah so we recommend just leaving it at
any and we will just pick the zone for
you from a capacity perspective this is
very essentially you size your Rattus
instance and as I mentioned if you look
at the network throughput as you
provision more memory size you get more
Network throughput the other important
aspect to remember is the the security
model for cloud memory stores so today
the security model we have essentially
is a really exposed wall memory store
using private IP right and the others
the security authorization that you can
have is that you can restrict the access
to a specific VPC in your project right
so that's what that's a current security
model we understand that there are cases
where you want to be able to have it
much further restriction at the instance
level so that's something that we are
working on enabling to have instance
level authentication for memory store
how many of you require instance level
off so the notion here is that if you
are authorizing just the VPC network
that means pretty much any VM that is
connected to that V PC network in that
project can access the Redis instance so
that's pretty much it and if you go into
the Advanced Options we have exposed a
few of the Redis configurations here we
haven't exposed all of them and this is
something that we try to do
intentionally in terms of exposing that
can fix but we exposed the main ones the
key one that you wanna understand watch
out for is max memory policy the max
memory policy by default we set it to
volatile LRU I'll talk more about the
eviction policies later on but that's
something that you want to be super
aware of in terms of what is a default
that we set and that's
all this I'll allow you that's it so you
click create oh [ __ ] I shouldn't use
this you can look create and that's
pretty much it that's that's all you
need to do to provision a reticences
and once you provision you basically get
the management capabilities right here
on the console we have essentially a
list of metrics that we expose in the
console itself that you can use to
monitor but the recommendation is that
you use stackdriver for monitoring fault
memory store because we expose a lot
more metrics and stackdriver compared to
the console and sack level also gives
you additional capabilities like
alerting etc so we will have a demo in
just a bit
to just talk about the different
capabilities or different monitoring
metrics that we have and what are some
of the things that you want to watch out
for when you monitor memory store how
many of you use share PPC in your
environment nobody the concept of shared
VPC is something that you probably will
want into if we start using GCP a lot
more so the concept is that you can
basically cut share a V PC network
across multiple projects there's a
concept of a host project and service
project meaning if you are let's say
from a developer's perspective we want
to be able to give our Ptolemy's to
individual application teams you can
basically create multiple service
projects and share this common network
across all of them so in that particular
case it's one of those things that if
you want to deploy 12 memory store into
one of those forever so this project
that is currently not supported that's
some one of the things that we are
working on so if you have that
particular use case that's something
that that will enable pretty quickly a
good example of that I wanted to mention
real quick we have customers who want to
set up a demo environment or Surya dev
or test environment where they
memory story instance across multiple
application for multiple versions of the
application and sure be PC would be
useful in that case so one of the other
important points that I want to make
with where we are with memory store is
that both basic tier and standard tier
instances are single master right so
that that becomes an interesting thing
to be aware of because obviously Redis
being single threaded there are certain
thresholds that you will hit pretty
quickly if it is a single massive based
on your workload so the solution for
that obviously is right is clustering we
haven't enabled Redis clustering yet in
cloud memory store so that's something
again that we are working on so that's
something that you need to be aware of
and I've seen this a few times where
customers look at standard tier and they
expect it to be a scale out marble right
but in this particular case it's just a
highly available read a sentence with a
single master has anybody deployed a
Redis cluster today by yourself and GCP
so now what I want to do is I want to
touch upon some of the best practices
around when using cloud memory store so
when I look at best practices and this
kind of spans mostly best practices
around Redis right and there are some
specific things around 12 memory sure
that you want to be aware of when you
are using the service so when you look
at the best practices around Redis I see
three I look at it as three buckets of
things one is there are things that you
can do in terms of storing data that you
can where you can do things to do things
more efficiently the other one is how do
you manage your evictions right and that
kind of ties in to you also the memory
the memory management aspects of Redis
and finally monitoring that's something
that we want to talk about very
specifically on twelve memory store
because there are certain things that we
do from a man is so this perspective
that'll be useful for
understand that'll help you to manage
your instances better from storing data
perspective there are a lot of very good
recommendations out there I just want to
touch upon like three things that we
find very useful from a redis
perspective right I think one of the
things is that if you can compress the
data whenever possible do that so there
are very good libraries like you know
Google's Google has a snappy library
that you can use to compress data so
that's that's a very good way where you
can depending on the kind of data that
you store in Redis you can even get like
up to 50% compressional so that's one of
the things that you should definitely
look into when you are using even memory
store because memory store behind the
scenes uses open source Redis right so
any best practices that you that applies
to open source Redis also applies to
twelve memory store the other one that
we see quite a bit is that in terms of
using the right serializer right Java
see realize that are notoriously
inefficient so there are some very good
C realizes out there Google's protobuf
is one way to serialize the data and
more efficiently if you if you want to
store it in a binary format so there are
a lot of good but that's one of the
things that you want to take a close
look at again in terms of how you store
data because again it's it's all about
how efficient you can be in terms of
memory because memory is expensive and
the more data you store that can quickly
add up and I mentioned this before a
hash using hash data structure to reduce
memory usage is again it all depends on
the kind of data that you're storing but
I think the key point that I want to
make here is that it's important for you
to look at it from a Redis perspective
and apply the best practices that you
would apply for Redis if you are
deploying it on your own even when you
are using cloud memory store right so
that's I think that's the key point that
I'm trying to make here when it comes to
best practices around storing data
eviction policy is very important very
very important then it's something that
you have to be super aware of and
eviction policy is all about how you
actually want your data and how long you
want to store data combined with how
much money you want to spend in a way
right so fundamentally eviction policies
as we all know is essentially the rules
that you apply to a big data from Redis
memory and based on certain
characteristics right so there are
basically two groups of eviction
policies there's the all or I would say
three there's no eviction which means
that it's essentially like a fixed
memory size that once you hit the memory
limit Bureau of Redis is not going to
affect any data and be essentially at
Redis is basically going to say we can't
store any more data in your in your
instance then there's all keys and
wallet I'll bei sell our use the wallet
ll are you like I said essentially is
what we enable as default and this is
something that we recommend it's an
interesting conversation when it comes
to eviction policy how many of you said
TTL Zinio Redis instance okay so the
interesting thing about volatile alar
you is that if you don't set the TTL
then that essentially means that there
is no piece that can be evicted right so
that's an interesting but at the same
time volatile volatile LRU is is a more
efficient way to manage your memory
because it essentially allows you to set
a TTL and evict or at least make the
expire the keys once you hit the TTL but
that requires a little bit more
understanding of your usage patterns and
you know how much you know what the keys
are used for and how long you want the
keys in memory etc but that allows you
to basically be a little bit more
efficient in terms of memory and how
much how large of an instance you want
to provision all keys allow you on the
other hand essentially what it says is
that
once you've hit the max memory it's
going to basically evict the least
recently used keys but you basically is
going to fill up the memory and then
start addicting keys so there are some
interesting consequences of doing all
Kiesel our users volatile area and we'll
talk about that in our bonnet ring best
practices and registers recently
introduced the lfyou policy where it is
it's a little bit more efficient
algorithm than LRU where it's more it's
it's all about how many times you have
access to the keys so LF you so that's a
also an interesting it you know compared
to LRU or similar to LRU again you just
need to have a very good a good sense of
how your keys are being used and then
using LRU or LF you will actually help
you with better memory management and
Redis the other key thing is how many of
you said are using cloud memory store
yeah have you guys run into memory
fragmentation is she on your side okay
so we take care of that so memory
fragmentation is a real problem in Redis
it's again like I said if you're using
open source right as you will run into
memory fragmentation problem and what
essentially what memory fragmentation
that is is basically
Redis has a concept of max memory right
that is essentially the memory that you
said for the Redis process but the wave
Redis allocate memory Redis can actually
consume more memory than what is
allocated for max memory so it'll
essentially creep into the system memory
that you provision or the excess memory
that you're provision in at some point
you will run out of system memory and
that'll cause a crash the reason memory
fragmentation happens is a few different
reasons if you have very if you have
homogeneous keys then the memory
allocation is pretty homogeneous in
width when you use the the the malloc
operator but if you have varying size
keys then it's quite possible that you
will run into a high fragmentation or
there's more chance of running into high
fragmentation so when high fragmentation
happens there's a bunch of memory that
is unusable
and then you quickly get into a
situation where Redis has to consume
more memory than what is allocated for
Redis and then you get into that issue
of basically running out a system memory
and that can potentially crash shredders
so one of the key things that you want
to watch out for is have things in place
that will allow you to detect memory
fragmentation and take action on it so
our best practices demo we will walk
through what is that you need to watch
out for because there are certain things
that we can do from a managed service
perspective there are things that we do
from a manager this perspective to
ensure that your systems are up and
running but there are also cases where
you want to be proactive about not
getting into a situation very high
memory fragmentation this problem was
actually worse in 3.2 but in 4.0 they
have introduced active defragmentation
also that when the instance is running
there's a background thread that
basically defraction memory this comes
with a cost of a higher CPU so this is
something that you basically want to
turn on and see for your workload what
the CPU overhead is but from based on
everything that we have seen in the
community and the testing that we have
done it seems to be a safe thing to turn
on but again depending on your birth lo
do you want to monitor your CPU when you
do this so monitoring fragmentation and
taking action is you know it's one of
the things that you if you start using
memory store you absolutely should know
how to do that and even if you're not
using memory so from a redis perspective
it is important to understand what are
some of the metrics that you should be
monitoring to make sure that your system
runs in a very stable manner so let's go
over that can we search the dough
so let me quickly walk through the snack
driver monitoring if you haven't used
stackdriver before so stackdriver is
Google Cloud monitoring platform so it's
like watch for AWS if you're familiar
with AWS so in snack driver what you can
do is you can essentially go look for
metrics so in this particular case you
can say Redis and we have exposed for
him a lot of metrics related to our
Redis over here right some so there's a
lot of metrics that you can monitor but
the question is what are the rights of
the metrics in monitor the baseline set
of metrics that you want to monitor and
what are some of the trends that you
want to watch out for and that's what I
that that's what we want to kind of talk
about here so what we have done is we
have created a couple of dashboards here
let me just go back so what we have here
is an instance where we are running a
benchmark behind the scenes we are using
running a mem tier benchmark so what we
are essentially doing doing is we have
created an instance with but the basic
of the default addiction policy was just
wallet silyl ru and we have said the
time to live to be very short right so
in this particular case as you can see
the max memory is set to 10 GB so the
first graph is essentially a graph
between max memory and user memory so
the zoom is actually running pretty
stable right now right so there's enough
memory available for Redis to consume
but that's one graph that you want to
monitor to ensure that your memory
consumption is is okay the next graph
which is the system memory usage ratio
is something that we just released so
this is essentially the graph that tells
you how much fragmentation do you have
in your system so system memory usage
ratio what we do when we manage the
service is that Redis obviously requires
many provision of reticence and you
obviously require some overhead
to take care of non dataset Greta's as a
whole bunch of background threads and
operations that that they do so there's
a recommendation of you know you need to
provision some system memory over max
memory to make sure that the system is
up and running in a stable fashion so we
take care of that today but the thing is
that you need to be able to aver even
then there will be fragmentation that
happens in your system so when you
monitor system memory usage ratio
essentially what you are looking for is
you want to look for whether the graph
is trending towards hundred percent
right so based on the overhead that we
provision behind the scenes your system
uses memory usage ratio will always
start at a percentage right typically
it's going to be around sixty percent
which is fine because that's based based
on the amount of overhead that be
provisioned behind the scenes but the
key thing that you want to watch out for
is what is a trend as your workload
Peaks and over a period of time whether
it's spending towards you know let's say
70 80 90 percent right so that's a key
graph to watch white spending
replication again is a very interesting
thing that you should always watch for
because Redis replication is
asynchronous right and depending on your
right load we can obviously have a
depending on the boom the right load and
the kind of instance that you have you
can have a pretty big replication back
wall and this is just the nature of
Redis so the what that tells you is that
whether your instance is able to sustain
the workload that you have running on
that particular instance the consequence
of bytes running replication going high
essentially is that it can also drive
higher memory consumption but also
register and get into this behavior of
doing a full synchronization once the
bytes running replication go below a
certain limit so that's again another
key graph to watch out for when you're
doing you know just managing Redis in
general but all these metrics are
exposed for years so you can just use
factor I were to do that the other
interesting one is keys you know the
number of keys was expire Abul keys
right it's like it's a good thing to
keep to understand in terms of hey first
of all if you're using wall tunnel are
you and if you don't see X parable keys
that's about saying right that means you
haven't really set TTL and you either
should set a TTL or you should change
your addiction policy to all keys are
Laurie can you scroll down actually a
few more things that you want to watch
out for is obviously CPU network
throughput is a good one to just keep an
eye on and advocate keys you can
understand so for example if you get run
into memory pressure and if you're not
seeing any evictions that's something
that we want you may want to take go
take a look at the failover one is also
an interesting one because there are
scenarios where we have to fail over the
instance without you knowing or
triggering just to make sure that the
system is in a stable state so it's very
good to know whether if multiple
failures happen in a period of time and
that can also have consequence to your
application because when we do a
failover
obviously we just you know disconnect
the clients so if you're running into
behaviors or scenarios where you're like
why that's my application you know
getting disconnected or if there is some
kind of inconsistency when you're
running like a job for example you do a
failover
because register application is
asynchronous there could be stable data
or potentially loss of data when that
happens so monitoring if failures are
happening in your environment is a good
way to understand if some of the
application behavior that is happening
is due to the fate over that's happening
in the system if you see a lot of
failures in the info memory store that
means there's something going on and you
know we will know about it we'll take
care of it but it's important for you
also to know that that's going on so
these I would say are the key metrics
that you should be monitoring regardless
you know whether things are bad or
happening or not when you provision
memory store you should be just
monitoring these metrics in your model
let's take a quick look at another down
out of their graph same sort of metrics
but the interesting thing here is that
we ran this benchmark and we set a long
TTL and that's essentially what I'm
talking about in terms of
memory usage ratio keep going up and we
kind of I think we solved a benchmark at
some point but if you continue to run
that benchmark for the instant size that
we had we essentially would have hit the
system memory usage ratio about hundred
percent at that point we will failover
right and we will try to keep the system
up and running but in some cases it can
get extreme where we are not able to or
the system is not able to recover itself
so that's the reason we recommend that
you monitor your system memory usage
ratio to be around eighty percent right
set an alert and stackdriver and the
action that you can take at that point
essentially is to scale your instance
right so that will essentially give you
more memory for the workload that you're
running so that's a very important graph
to keep an eye on and also put some load
song so I talked about monitoring system
memory usage ratio and then triggering
an alert the question is and also said
hey do you want to do scaling right so
one of the so the question is what is it
what is an efficient way to do it Karthi
do you want to talk about sure so as we
were as we were kind of working through
this demo one of the things we wanted to
showcase is the fact that in addition to
the reliability that you get with cloud
memory store for rhetta's instead of you
know as opposed to running Redis on your
own is the GCP ecosystem of services
that you get to use and this is a good
example of that where as Gopal mentioned
you look at these trends for example
system memory ratio and other things as
they as they you know trend in a
direction you want to take action you
could take manual you can take action
manually or you could automate it and
this is one way to do it the reason we
want to talk about doing it this way is
because it's fully server lists and
server list is all the rage you're not
standing up separate VMs and things like
that and this counts on the fact that
stack driver is essentially a giant time
series database so you can inspect you
know the metrics that you're interested
in inspecting for example the ones that
Gopal pointed to and you can do that on
a scheduled basis
as I'll show you we're gonna do it once
every minute sample the metrics that
we're interested in kind of seeing the
trends for and then based on how they're
trending you can actually use a cloud
function to scale up your cloud memory
store for Redis instance and this is
because we give you an API just like
with every service that GCP has cloud
memory store has an API to initiate a
scale up so you can automate this so
let's look at that real quick
if we could switch back to the demo so I
mentioned the cloud scheduler service
this is a service that we recently
released you don't want to stand up a VM
and run cron on it you want to you want
to use a reliable service for this the
way this works is you can set up you can
set up the service to generate at
pub/sub message and then you know in
this case we're gonna do it once a
minute and then based on the pub/sub
message getting deposited into a topic
you can run a cloud function and I'll
quickly talk through this cloud function
I don't want to take up too much time I
hope there are folks who or most of the
folks in this room hopefully you know
Python essentially what we're gonna do
is check to see if our system memory
usage ratio is trending up rapidly and
that is up to you to decide and then
another thing we have to pay attention
to if you remember we were tracking was
the byte spending replication we want to
make sure that this is not some crazy
number where it's like eight gigs behind
you don't want to trigger replication I
mean trigger a scale-up event at that at
that time because you might have data
loss so you have to balance this and
what I would recommend is you know try
to get ahead of the situation where if
you're seeing growth early on and you
know the growth is going to continue on
then triggers trigger this kind of a
scale-up event and then at that point
you decide you know how much to scale up
by in this case I just randomly picked
two and you call up the call to scale-up
function which uses the cloud memory
store for Redis Python SDK
and basically you know sets the memory
size to the new value that you would
like it to have of course you want to
make sure that you do this you know with
some boundaries in mind because
obviously we have a limit of 300 gigs
and you may have some you know limits in
terms of budgets and things like that
keep that in mind when you automate it
but it is recommended that you automate
this you know within reason all right
thank you very much it is
[Music]